bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement jordi
j'accueille hugh laurie qui est morte de
rire je sais pas comment ça va partir
mais salue miro comment ça va je pensais
pas que vous pouvez maintenant suis
encore en train de manger mes petits
bonbons honda tu m'a invité dans un
endroit super on est directeur du palais
de la découverte dans le planétarium on
peut lire ceci n'est pas d'image donc
mieux et l'astronome adjointe marie sud
ouest et u d'astrophysique spatiale est
ce que je peux juste te prendre
tellement ton parcours
on entendra arriver là encore moins une
minute
alors comment je suis arrivé là jusqu'en
sa vague comme tu le sens je pense que
c'est intéressant
donc j'ai fait un bac s après bac je
suis parti j'ai fait des études en maths
sup maths spé
et donc pour exister en veut toujours
faire de la soupe sûr que en fait quand
j'ai intégré une école d'ingénieurs je
m'intéressais plus sur la physique des
particules et c'est un peu par concours
de circonstances où je me suis retrouvé
à faire un master en physique nucléaire
et en ingénierie nucléaire
donc j puisque si l école d'ingé j'étais
plus dans la branche ingénierie
nucléaire
non puisque autre chose on avait quand
même des cours de physique nucléaire qui
était vraiment sympa et en option il y
avait un cours de physique des plasmas
donc peut-être que je peux expliquer ce
que sont les placements dieu explique
c'est quoi un plasma c'était comme un
placement a donc un plasma c'est un état
de la matière où le gaz est tellement
chaud que les atom ont perdu des
électrons d'en face est un gaz qui est
complètement ironisé
mais au lieu de se battre au lieu de
trouver la matière sous la forme soit
solide liquide ou gazeuse comme on le
rencontre en rencontre dans la vie de
tous les jours impasse masse et des
conditions de température de pression
tellement extrêmes comme un attaquant
lenteur des étoiles que les gaz de son
sont complètement ionisé est ce que j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment chouette parce que on
avait fait des études et des travaux
pratiques
alors c'était plutôt la simulation
numérique à l'époque où on a lié les
équations de maxwell dans les équations
de l'électromagnétisme avec les
équations d'un fluide on commence quand
suite se comportent en présence d'un
champ magnétique lto-3 super génial
équation assez horrible pour ceux qui je
trouve que les et passion maxwell sont
tout à fait fascinante et en plus elles
sont vraiment je trouve que elle marque
aussi le changement entre la physique
jusqu'au 19ème siècle et le démarrage on
va dire du 20e siècle avec la
compréhension de base au delà la
finitude de la vitesse de la lumière qui
l'a amené einstein à la relativité
relativité restreinte et c'est donc
chose que c'est des équations qui sont
très élégantes et en même temps bayh
avait cet aspect fluides ou bali fluide
c'est un peu la vie de tous les jours
mais qui dont le mouvement peut être
complètement modifié par par ces champs
magnétiques et électriques et le
l'agencement des deux pour moi j'ai
trouvé ça moi j'ai pas à ça maintenant
fait le plus de bruit ça beau est ce que
j'ai lu que les casinos sont admis king
des fluides toutes les équations de
navier stokes son passé c'est un
problème très connue des mathématiques à
100 dès ses premiers millénaires de
savoir comprendre cette équation même
l'énoncé assez fumeux choix c'est
maintenant comprendre cette équation
sait pas trop ce qu'on est et tout ça ça
ne suffit pas il faut être quand même
rajouter en plus ces équations de
maxwell dessus mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque je me rendais pas compte à quel
point c'était
là je trouve que c'est une relativement
élégant et que les équations de fluides
était relativement va dire passe-t-il
comparé à patron de la physique
quantique pour moi c'était beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus difficile parce que
beaucoup plus abstrait mais c'est vrai
que quand tu commences à regarder les
équations fluide et surtout dans leur
contexte de plasma donc l'équivalent on
va dire que c'est la magnéto
hydrodynamique ou l'hydrodynamique
associé au magnétisme enfin
l'électromagnétisme en fait on se rend
compte qu'il ya plein de problèmes et
pourquoi ai-je bien parce que en fait
quand on considère un fils par exemple
un écoulement d'eau basse et des
molécules d'eau dans l'enclos id alors
que dans un plasma on peut avoir disions
des électrons qui vont se comporter de
manière différente et donc les étrangers
et on met les yeux on peut avoir des
gens de nature différente et donc ça
complexifie encore plus les choses et on
a des des degrés de complexité
on cache un peu en fait avec les
équations de la manita hydrodynamique
est en fait si on rentre un peu plus à
l'intérieur c'est tout c'est
pratiquement le pont avec la physique
des particules
alors pas vraiment la physique quantique
mais vraiment comment comment les
particules peuvent pas transporter
comment un ce qu'elles peuvent être
énergisé me et en fait ça touche a pas
tellement de domaines de la physique
c'est aussi pour ça que j'avais je pense
une attirance pour l'art les petits
déplacements que mais parce que je peux
sur commande quand tu es les équations
de mener tôt hydrodynamique
ouais parce que tout est moyenne donc
ces particules alors non en fait je
considère que tu as un placement qui
neutralise sont neutralisés et est donc
en quelque sorte on s'en fiche un peu de
savoir quelle est la composition ou
qu'est ce qu'on appelle un fluide
nick walker et après tu peux tu peux
aller plus loin en disant ben en fait
c'est pas un pli de mes sites de fluides
et puis elle est très négatif un puits
de positif que de charge électrique et
après tu peux aller plus loin nous on en
a déjà plein de
ok tu peux décliner ses décors sont en
fête géante à prendre inverse
tu commence vraiment avec les partis on
va dire des écoulements de particules
donc de considérer un très grand nombre
de particules à partir duquel qui va
faire des distributions de particules et
tu dis bon bah en fait on moyenne un peu
la chose est en arrive aux équations de
l' image des bleus mais dans mon
parcours j'ai pas été introduit comme ça
j'ai plutôt été introduite par la
magnétohydrodynamique et j'ai appris
plus tard en fait en physique des
plasmas quand on fait vraiment la
physique des plasmas
on commence d'abord par une description
on va dire de ces particules d'un grand
nombre de particules et qu'on arrive à
la mhd en simplifiant petit à petit
donc je sais pas si ce moment et du coup
quand est-ce que d'autres où ça beau la
preuve que le but c'est trop et a trouvé
ça beau je me rappelle pas j'ai alors je
me rappelle qu'on avait commencé je me
répète enlevés dans l'est plus
grotesques on a commencéà fallait
l'électromagnétisme ça c'est en prépa et
j'aimais bien encore une fois je
trouvais ça que je trouvais que c'était
très élégant c'est j'aime beaucoup les
jeux traditionnels à la formulation
vectorielles et et je me rappelle ma
première année de prépa je n'avais rien
compris tout ce qui était rotationnelle
et le moment j'ai compris en fait c'est
vraiment un jeu passait vraiment ça
c'est un voyage noba fois par mois je
trouve des trucs plus bizarre que ça moi
j'ai fait un bocal on a sorti les
régions belges et je pense que j'ai même
encore un peu un blocage sur sur les e
dp en général que mais en particulier
sur tout ce qui est rotationnelle
done to web bizarrement encore une fois
pendant pendant quelques temps j'ai un
peu de mal à comprendre
et puis j'ai eu un déclic et puis les
vecteurs ça m'a paru alors en avaient
tous quittés matrix j'aimais bien ça
j'aime bien cette distinction en
mathématiques évoquant physique ont osé
pas mal de de calcul de la crise avec
les mecs
oui c'est vraiment bizarre et je pense
que c'était ce côté un peu plus
mathématique avec les vecteurs qui m'a
attiré alors qu'encore une fois alors
que j'étais parti puces dont la physique
des particules
la physique quantique m'a beaucoup moins
parler que l'éléctromagnétisme et après
je sais pas je pense que c'est peut-être
aussi des questions de base deux profs
sur qui tu ton mec qui tue bien ce sont
les personnes qui arrivent à temps
sufrir du coup ton prof de mécanique
quantique été horrible c'est ça non
c'était pas le même c'était dans le jeu
n'en a pas et j'avais hier un court je
comprenais rien et c'était dans un amphi
jeter passée près juste un bleu ne
voulait pas et je pense que c'est une
question aussi de de temps peut-être que
j'avais j'étais moins à ce moment là
j'étais peut-être je l'aide arrive en
école et le gt pas dans la même
perspective
moi je voulais puissent profiter de et
12% pour continuer sa femme a en fait a
mené plus tôt à la physique des plasmas
plutôt qu à l'astrophysique
j'avais toujours en tête que je voulais
a cliqué ça à l'astrophysique et en fait
encore une fois c'est vraiment des
circonstances
et c'est là où ça c'est marrant c'est
que même si on a une sorte de vision de
ce que l'on veut faire finalement les
choses les choses changent avec l'âge
des opportunités et dans mon cas j'ai
l'opportunité de faire un stage à jack
tu le gie
tpour le zhang yuping torres qui est en
fait un tokamak donc une chambre
magnétisé qui permet de confiner le
plasma et qui permettrait un qui permet
les tokamaks peuvent permettre aux spurs
en reste sûre d'accéder à l'énergie de
la fusion nucléaire
en fait reproduire ces conditions
drastiques de température et de pression
comme ce qu'on a dans les étoiles pour
essayer de recréer l'énergie de fusion
que l'on trouve au sein des étoiles
d'aucuns ma classe et trucs en forme je
veux dire de tort je passais les gens
voient ce que c'est un peu internet et
parfois des images de nucléaire avec qui
tourne ici on tapisse a survolé le
plasma l'intérieur effectivement une
rotation mais voilà du coup je me suis
retrouvé à travailler pendant un stage
sur sur ça et c'était en préparation ou
d'une d'une année que j'allais passer au
japon et l'appareil que j'avais cherché
plutôt pillé déplacement mais à l'époque
je pensais que celle être appliquée à
l'astrophysique et en fait pas du tout
je me suis retrouvé à être embarqué dans
dans la communauté de la fusion
nucléaire
donc en fait je suis arrivé en jeu dix
étudiantes un échange avec l'université
au japon à kyoto et à l'époque oui je
alors je les faire du plus tôt la
physique théorique et la physique des
plasmas et donc j'ai continué c'est très
intéressant sur un phénomène que l'on
appelle la reconnexion magnétique
en fait la reconnexion magnétique c'est
quand on a des du champ magnétique qui
va se reconfigurer et on se reconfigurer
en fait il va essayer de chercher un est
un peu plus relax et et en se relaxant
fait il va libérer énormément d'énergie
et on pense que c'est un mécanisme qui
est au coeur de deux plein de phénomènes
astrophysiques les éruptions solaires
mais aussi des dés par exemple dans les
pulsars
son appel et alors j'avais prévenu que
je des fois je manque de mots en
français
je pense que ça va les noyaux actifs de
galaxies
on a d'énormes g22 des jets de matière
qui sont liés on pense à ce phénomène de
reconnexion magnétique et donc ça
m'intéressait de de commencer à
travailler sur un processus fondamental
que l'on retrouve un peu partout dans
l'univers est donc à l'issue de cette
année donc moi dira même au milieu de
mon année je cherchais à l'époque à
faire une thèse et j'avais déjà contacté
des gens en france pour continuer à
faire une thèse en france et à mon
professeur au japon ma vez ira si jamais
tu veux rester on pourrait appliquer sa
l'astrophysique ans je connais quelqu'un
qui sera orienté action et je me suis
fait avoir parce que je venais
rencontrer cette personne qu à
l'informateur de tout le temps après
j'ai fait en rigolant parce que j'ai
quand même passé un très bon moment et
ça m'a quand même permis justement de
connaître une communauté de la fusion
nucléaire et au final alors j'ai eu
quand même pas mal de chance mais j'ai
quand même pu bifurquer à la fin c'est
quand même très difficile on a peut-être
des certains de tes aux auditeurs et
auditrices qui veulent peut-être faire
une thèse à l'issue de laquelle en fait
on ne se connaît pas les post doctorat
est allé parce doctorat ça se prépare
c'est des gens que l'on gens que l'on
connaît qu'on a vu en conférence qui ça
qui connaissent le travail de notre test
qui vont vraisemblablement de recruter
et moi j'étais confronté à ce problème
de ne pas ne pas connaître la communauté
astrophysique et et au début c'était
j'avais un peu peur de changer de
domaine mais je me suis dit je la
matière la recherche est tellement dure
en soi que si en plus j'arrive pas à
continuer autant m'amuser pendant
quelques années à faire des trucs que
j'ai vraiment envie de faire
et donc j'ai j'ai eu la chance de
trouver une bourse postdoctorale ou bien
sûr trop je suis revenu en france et à
ce moment j'ai travaillé en physique
solaire à l'observatoire de paris
google et là j'ai vraiment commencé à me
spécialiser toujours sur les personnes
mais en physique solaire et 20 la forme
de ce premier post doctorat et ensuite
je suis parti rang pendant deux ans au
royaume uni je me suis de plus en plus
changé j'ai agrandi mon champ de
recherche pour intégrer les plasma dans
le milieu interplanétaire savent tous
les millions entre le soleil et les
planètes du système solaire
donc là c'est un peu le pas ce que tu
parlais de déplacements qu'on d'énergie
très chaud et compression alors
classement je dirais que non parce qu'en
fait la l'atmosphère du soleil grands
problèmes de la firme solaire à la cnas
heures de sommeil est très très chaude
l'étonnement très chaude en fait elles
devraient être de moins en moins chaud
puisque on s'éloigne de plus en plus du
quart du soleil et en fait non celle
inverse a fait très chaud dans
l'atmosphère du soleil et de toute façon
tout est sous forme de placement et le
sujet de mes recherches pendant ma tête
ce qui était sur la reconnexion
magnétique
en fait cette reconnexion magnétique on
pense qu'elle a lieu partout dans
l'atmosphère du soleil et en particulier
c'est un phénomène qui va libérer
énormément d'énergie lors des éruptions
solaires et une fois qu'on a saisi rup
sion solar on va créer en femme j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de la reconnexion
comme étant une sorte de restructuration
du champ magnétique est un
cette restructuration fait elle va
envoyer des chromes structure des grands
nuages magnétique et de placement dans
l'espace dont je continue toujours sur
la physique des plasmas sur la
reconnexion magnétique
mais cette fois-ci vraiment impliqué au
soleil et au milieu interplanétaire
hockey parce que j'étais pas loin mais
les craintes et milieu interplanétaire
sera entre les planètes du coup dur et
c'est raymond du soleil ouais d'alors
ouais arrête ça dépend c'est c'est tout
l'effectif mans le milieu entre les
planètes et le soleil et les planètes
c'est tout ce qui est ce qu'on appelle
l'héliosphère donc c'est en fait le
système solaire dans lequel tu retrouves
le champ magnétique du soleil ont même
si ce qu'on n'a pas le vent solaire
tiens et comment constante de particules
chargées nous allons du soleil pour pas
que des particules change on aussi des
autres où donc ouais c'est ça alors ça
peut être très proche du soleil dans
lequel l'amosphère ça peut être moins
proches en cas de marqueur
plus on s'éloigne plus une fiction cm du
soleil noir et on est toujours sous la
sphère d'influencé du soleil le capa
devises en fait ouais ouais mais c'est
quand même trois oui alors c'est foi
puissent est très peu dense mais on a
justement ces structures
ces structures qui qui ce pointu se
propage avait des particules qui elles
sont un peu plus chaudes
donc ouais d'où ces mêmes équations des
libéraux est en fait là ça tombe encore
plus au sens d'utiliser ces équations de
la manipule hydrodynamique
parce que on regarde des structures qui
sont tellement énormes que finalement
alors ça des parias des deux personnes
qui vont s'intéresser justement aux
particules et est plutôt a par exemple à
la distribution de ces particules à la
turbulence
moi quand je m'intéresse plutôt à des
microstructures magnétique
je m'intéresse plus à un écoulement on à
dire global ont plutôt un plasma ou je
regarde pas vraiment ce qui se passe au
niveau des électrons et d étaient des
yeux mais plutôt aux champs magnétiques
et au plasma général n'ont donc les
équations dame hd ou encore plus de sens
donc là les hypothèses
et pour ce qui sera un peu perdu dans
tout ça pourquoi est ce important
c'était important
pourquoi c'est alors déjà pourquoi ces
séries portant déjà pour sa avancer la
recherche le champ de ma connaissance
c'est la raison pour laquelle on fait
des recherches
mais ce qui est intéressant dans dans ce
domaine là c'est qu'on a vraiment eu une
application directe une conséquence
directe de ces recherches bien parce que
en fait sur terre on n'est pas
complètement on attendait pas on est
soumis à l'activité du soleil
donc on sait que le soleil c'est
important pour nous parce que on a
besoin d'eux on a besoin de ça de sa
chaleur mais en fait ces particules se
vendent particules qui nous arrive
en fait peu alors la plupart sont
défraîchis par le champ magnétique de la
terre ce qu'on appelle la magnétosphère
mais de temps en temps en fait on peut
avoir des particules qui vont de soi qui
vont directement rentré dans la
magnétosphère et c'est encore plus le
cas quand on va avoir des tempêtes
solaires ou c zéro pensez-y roxon ceux
là sont la fois associé à des particules
très énergétiques mais aussi à ces
grandes structures dont je parlais avant
des tempêtes solaires qui elles vont
venir en quelque sorte frappé la côte
magnétique de la terre et ça ça va
engendrer ce qu'on appelle des orages
géomagnétiques donc ça peut paraître
encore abstrait on peut dire au nez
pourquoi c'est important
et puis ça impacte aussi toutes nos
technologies
en fait le plus on connaît le soleil
puis on se rend compte qu'on est
vulnérable parce qu'en fait en observant
le soleil on a aussi développé des
techniques comme par exemple là comme
par exemple le spatial qui sont enfin le
numérique est vulnérable à l'activité du
soleil et donc par exemple pour le
soleil pas pour le le spatial li lé
orbite des satellites peuvent être
modifiées lorsqu'on à ces orages
magnétiques
on peut aussi avoir lorsqu'on a des
particules énergétiques on peut avoir
des effets sur sur les composants les
composants peuvent être endommagés ça
peut être
aussi très important pour nos
astronautes là on a parlé récemment des
missions apollo donc attendu beaucoup de
chance de ne pas avoir de particules
très énergique
à ce moment là et puis sur terre on peut
aussi avoir des effets sur les réseaux
électriques et
et puis plein de choses comme par
exemple il ya des missions des émissions
radios ont certes une certaine gamme
d'émissions radio qui est notamment
utilisé pour mai les radioamateurs mais
aussi pour les radios de de
télécommunications pour ce pur à combler
pour secourir les les populations qui
pourraient être touchés par des
catastrophes naturelles pas ce qui s'est
passé par exemple pour l'ouragan irène
au même moment on avait une éruption
solaire qui a engendré ce qu'on appelle
un black out en communication radio et
on va tomber mais on peut plus utiliser
les communications radios sont donc on a
un effet direct sur si on lui faisait
aussi le risque de surcharge du réseau
cause du coût des blocs électriques et
ça c'est en a causé en fait dans
l'histoire on a on a toute une liste
d'éléments départ de signaux gps aussi
ce que je parle hélas les black cats
radio les la carte de réseau électrique
départ de satellites aussi tout ça en
fait ça nous a déjà impacté dans le
passé c'est pas juste quelque chose qui
pourrait arriver c'est des choses qui
sont déjà qu'ils ont qui sont déjà
arrivées avoir des conséquences sur un
plan de jeu pas que l'industrie qui soit
qu'est ce qui peut se passer de très
grave mais si l'industrie dépend
beaucoup de ces communications ont donné
des millions aux démineurs exactement
alors un exemple pour une industrie qui
a qui perdent récupère énormément
énormément d'argent
c'est par exemple l'industrie pétrolière
après mais pas dans l'industrie
pétrolière qui se sert du gps pour aller
creuser
sous les océans qui ont besoin d'une
position très très précise de la ou les
forages vont aller et ne serait ce que
quelques quelques degrés de différence
en fait c'est des millions de do
pération des 10 millions de dollars de
dollars celle pas en quoi ça sert des
millions de dollars d'opérations qui
sont perdus d'un coup et s'assure des
des signaux gps qui peuvent être perdue
sur quelques heures à cause de ces des
options solaire est utilisé un truc
aussi sur les missions apollo la chance
ouais ouais alors en fait ça c'est
quelque chose que je savais mais je
n'avais pas vraiment regarder moi même
et cet été j'ai acheté à une conférence
et j'ai parlé de justement de ce qu'on
appelle la météorologie spatiale
enfin la maîtrise de l'espace plutôt la
météorologie de l'espace c'est vraiment
essayer de comprendre les effets de
l'activité du soleil sur sur les
planètes du système solaire et j'avais
cherché un peu comme on venait juste de
fêter les 50 ans de des premiers humains
sur la lune
je me suis dis bah j'ai regardé comme
j'avais déjà entendu parler du fait que
les missions apollo avait eu pas mal de
chance en fait c'est assez marrant c'est
que je suis tombé sur une vidéo
j'ai pas réussi à la retrouver parce que
j'ai pas accès ya un reportage qui a été
fait sur les missions apollo sur la
chaîne national geographic et on voit un
moment dans le film une interview d de
l'équipage d'apollo 8 dont la première
mission a habité autour de la lune et on
leur demande mais ce ne sera pas un
problème les effets de radiations que
l'on part sur les mêmes puisque la nulle
et n'est plus protégé par cette bulle
magnétique de la terre est en fait un
des astronautes a dit non et je pense
qu'en fait c'était un an
il était très au courant fait parce que
en fait de la nasa avait déjà fait des
rapports sur la place les les
conséquences on rentre pas les
conséquences mais quelle était la
démarche à suivre dans le cas où ont
détecté des particules énergétiques vous
avez déjà les détecteurs les les
astronautes aussi a vu des décomptes
heures de natation et cette personne à
qui avait répondu en fait été l'ex terre
et la lune même été recruté parce qu'il
est expert en radiation je pense qu'ils
savaient très bien mais que voulez pas
inquiéter les personnes est en fait en
remontant ce que maintenant on peut
remonter dans passé en fait les missions
apollo son parti à peu près au maximum
de l'activité du soleil vague le soleil
est une activité qui dure à peu près 11
à 13 ans est au maximum de son activité
c'est là on va avoir plein d'éruption et
en fait quand on regarde ni sur un peu
l'oeil sont vraiment parti pendant ce
maximum d'activités et on sait que en
fait on a eu des événements à particules
énergétiques entre certaines missions je
crois que la plus grande qui aurait pu
être fatale pour les astronautes je
crois que c'était quelques mois après la
mission apollo d'apollo 15 ou entre
d'asta 0,17 mais voilà ce n'est pas la
bonne cause
ok je vais revenir un peu assez de
l'origine du vent solaire et depuis des
tempêtes aussi ouais pas d'où ça vient
tout ça tout ça vient l'art en fait j'ai
parlé des délégués j'ai parlé de la
physique des plasmas et ce lien entre
les champs magnétiques janvier traité
est un plasma dion et d'électro en fait
les les étoiles ont tous les étoiles
dans l'univers sont composés duo et
d'électrons parce qu'en fait ça sont
tellement chaude que les atomes on part
de ces électrons et en fait c'est aussi
des des des corps célestes en rotation
sur un homme comme la terre comme jamais
et on a fait cette rotation là elle va
engendrer un mouvement du plasma
qui va générer un champ magnétique c'est
équivalent en déplaçant champ un champ
de particules chargées et ça va générer
un champ magnétique
donc ça c'est vraiment il ya une boîte
six ans elle voit deux dans les
équations de maxwell qui montre
exactement ça ces histoires de rotation
comparer ça génère et donc les les
étoiles en rotations vont vont former
leurs champs magnétiques et ce champ
magnétique en fait il est principalement
construit à l'intérieur ou de ces
étoiles dans dans l'oeil du soleil la
zone convective et la zone on va trouver
cette génération enfin quant à la base
de la zone convective et ce champ
magnétique en fait il n'est pas juste
confiné et va s'étendre jusqu'aux
confins du système solaire
et c'est ce qu'on appelle l'héliosphère
en fait l'héliosphère c'est la bulle
magnétique du soleil la magnétosphère
c'est la bulle magnétique terrestre et
est en fait ce champ magnétique qui
s'étend jusqu'aux jusqu'aux confins de
vue du système solaire et le long de ces
deux champs magnétiques et bien on va
avoir un écoulement de particules qui va
être ce vent solaire de parce que doublé
porte une charge et suivent les lignes
d'eau chaude exactement et donc ça c'est
on va dire un soleil calme qui générait
son banc solaire tout le temps son champ
magnétique tout le temps et qui en plus
se tourner sur lui-même donc ça fait une
sorte de structure
ce qu'on appelle à la la jupe de
ballerines parce qu'en effet dû à la
rotation du soleil en fait ce fut le
champ magnétique va sur marché des
mouvements avec j -p donc ça c'est ce
qu'on n'aurait en permanence sauf que ce
qui se passe en fait c'est comme le
soleil n'est pas un une boule solide
amateurs l'institut face en fait c'est
que on a une différence de rotation à
l'équateur et au pôle ce qu'on appelle
ou une rotation différentiel parce que
c'est différent à l'équateur et aux
bonnes
en fait on en fait cette différence de
rotation qu'est ce qu'elle va faire si
on imagine que ça un champ magnétique
uniforme c'est maintenant on commence à
tourner beaucoup plus rapidement un
endroit donné
ces lignes de chant elles vont commencer
à tourner aussi beaucoup plus rapidement
que d'autres points donc ça ça va
commencer à entortillé le champ
magnétique que c'est comme si je prenais
un élastique dans mes mains il ya donc
je le tiens de chaque côté par mon coup
c'est mon index créé et ça me rend ma
main droite a commencé à en sortir
donc c'est à dire que la main gauche
elle reste statique et même endroit ça
commence à tourner donc ça ça va en
bobines et le plastique et a donc on
peut s'imaginer 7 tortillements est en
fait c'est intensément du champ
magnétique va en fait générer localement
des sortes de champs magnétiques
entortillé que l'on voit apparaître sur
la surface du soleil comme étant des
taches solaires
on sait des endroits qui sont plutôt
sombres sur la surface du soleil quand
le soleil est vu ce qu'on a fait en
lumière blanche droit en lumière visible
on voit cet âge solaire alors pas
regarder le soleil alpes à l'oeil nu
mais si on le voyait à l'oignon verrait
ses taches solaires option projette une
image de soleil sur mon goût pratique
par exemple et dans ces endroits là ce
sont concentrés les champs magnétiques
convaincant à tartiers google et
notamment si je reviens à mon analogue
de ce set élastique que géant tortille
quand je les entends ticket ce qui se
passe si je continue à en sortir mais
pas mal d'énergie du coup pas dans son
cas c'est marrant qui casseront j'étais
tout droit il n'a su courber voilà alors
j'ai fait plein de gestes comme ça pour
eux elle qu'est ce que ça fait ça donc
mais ça commence en fait à scorer ccsa
ce qui va émerger dans le dans
l'inconscient du soleil
du coup comme ça commence à tourner ça
se fait piller naturellement mais la
tâche est afin de voir si une
explication mathématiques on parle d les
citer tous cas il ya une formulation
magnétique qu'on appelle à les citer
magnétique qui peut représenter 7 ce
twist enfin cette en tortillant est en
fait toute cette partie là et finalement
c'est aussi ce que j'aime beaucoup avec
la physique solaire c'est que six ans
dont on n'a pas parlé mais la série que
certaines personnes peuvent se dire
pourquoi étudier le soleil alors qu'il
ya tellement d'autres étoiles dans
l'univers en fait le soleil c'est un une
étoile c'est la seule étoile
à l'heure actuelle dont on a une vision
on va dire à haute définition
tous les autres résultats sont vraiment
très loin et on n'a pas encore et puis
il nous faudrait des miroirs géants pour
pourvoir aux halak autant de définitions
le soleil mois et on ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que contrairement à des à
des astronomes qui est des
astrophysiciens qui verrait des des
étoiles et qui sont très peu contrainte
pour les observations tu peux imaginer
où par exemple en les exoplanètes pour
moi moi ça me fascine
j'adore tout ça est d'ailleurs j'aime
les mre tu peux inventer un alors de
moins bons parce que justement on
commence à voir de plus en plus de sa
ration mais tu parenté et n'importe quel
monde ce que tu veux des mondes avec ce
pas dit que la raison pour laquelle je
voulais faire de l'astrophysique c'était
pour trouver des aliens notre chat ça
laisse énormément de place à
l'imaginaire tout en jouant avec quand
même de la physique que l'on connaît je
dirais la très belle chose mais aussi la
complication avec le soleil c'est que on
peut pas tout imaginer parce que le
soleil et nous donne des contraintes non
et
et donc c'est à la fois c'est à la fois
de l'astrophysique ans de l'astronomie
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
fractions de l'astrophysique parce qu'on
essaie de comprendre les processus
physiques mais aussi beaucoup de
mathématiques et en fait il ya là où
j'étais en écosse j'étais en fait dans
un département de mathématiques ou bien
il ya des endroits où c'est vraiment de
la mathématique appliquée à la physique
solaire de colocation me dit que ma par
exemple la conservation de les citer ok
comment je connais comment ce que tu
commences que tu ou par exemple là je
parlais des éruptions solaires
les éruptions solaires donc c'est ce
sont ces structures qui ont emmagasiné
vend énormément d'énergie et qui à un
moment donné vont devenir instable donc
après ça fait des calculs d'instabilité
donc par exemple autre chose par exemple
c'est quand on a des irruptions est ce
que on pourrait on pourrait voir ça
comme quand même le dire en français des
systèmes qui se sont auto organise donc
une mais de manière critique donc en
anglais ça s'appelle savent organize
côté qualité c'est la même chose que les
tremblements de terre que les volcans en
fait tu peux avoir une approche
mathématique sur est ce que tu peux jean
les mots des matières mathématiques
c'est par exemple et les tas de sable
s'est tu rajoutes du sable du moins sa
forme une pyramide et un moment donné tu
as tu as a atteint un état critique
et quand tu mets un grain de sable tout
s'effondre et tutus reconstruit à ta
pyramide et puis un moment ça serait ça
se répondre à ce que tu peux représenter
la la temporalité des des séismes ou des
volcans ou des éruptions solaires comme
des états qui sont critiques n'ont
qu'eux et qui se sont auto organise de
façon critique donc une faille à tous où
tout un pan ou plutôt mathématiques
auxquelles c'est de décrire ce genre de
phénomène j'ai fait encore perturbé par
ceux ci font leur apparition
ben hatira gide en fait au début tu
constantin au préalable à jour là bas sa
base était un moment donné tu pourras
imagine qu'ils qui vit sous que
s'effondre pas complètement cojo alors
ça s'effondre peut-être pas complètement
mais ça c'est encore le pic a tué ce que
tu peux pas en faire un à l'infini pour
me voyez quelqu'un ça va être la chaire
d une plage d'accord enfin delta
produits du terroir alors non alors je
dirais que il y avait des gens qui y
vont vraiment poussé le côté
mathématique des choses moi je suis
plutôt à utiliser ses outils pour
essayer de comprendre la physique qui va
y avoir mais mais mais le côté
analytique way des choses qui sont très
intéressantes et encore une fois chaud
que c'est
c'est fascinant parce que à la fois tu
rentres dans des maths et de la physique
mais en plus tu as les autres actions et
en plus on a la chance je sais pas si tu
as vu enfin c'est juste que je tends
déjà montré des images du soleil maison
magique et je pense que j'ai encore une
fois quand je parlais de question de
faire de deux circonstances j'ai là la
fin de ma thèse a coïncidé à peu près
avec les débuts d'une mission spatiale
de la nasa qui s'appelle solar dynamics
observatory qui nous donne les images de
la plus haute résolution spatiale et
temporelle qu'on n'ait jamais eu du
soleil entier donc on a des certains en
ce moment qu'ils sont meilleurs en terme
de résolution
donc on va beaucoup mieux mais qui se
sont juste sur des angles sur des ja
zone du soleil là on a le soleil en
entier en définition 4k
donc on sait une très haute définition
ça doit passer des heures à regarder les
images vidéo du soleil alors ça
m'arrivait avant were here is an grâce
notamment au sirpa des arbres que je
sais pourquoi mais plus trop maintenant
ouais bon soyons malheureusement mais
j'aimerais bien avoir plus de temps à
contempler et je le fais pour certains
projets de recherche ou où je vais
regarder en face et ssh cas c'est
marrant c'est que je vais passer des
heures à regarder on va dire un
équivalent de d'une journée voire deux
sur le soleil et on voit tellement de
choses que parfois j'ai un peu trop
souple sous le choc mais parce que du
coup quand tu vois une vidéo du soleil
tu vois plein de choses va tu te dis à
acquérir là il ya un truc daily cité à
deux tours wyatt allemand de structure
il ya tellement de choses qui se passe
c'est vrai ils nettoient demande
dynamique et on sait pas la plus
dynamique de tous les étoiles mais en
tout cas de la sueur que l'on voir
doivent être devenu lors les champs
magnétiques
oui parce qu'en fait alors à dominer
papa tu pas tout le champ magnétique ou
mais quand on va voir ces gens
s'activent donc ces régions qui sont
associés à ces taches solaires
en fait tu vas voir des structures qui
sont indicatrices du champ magnétique
est le champ magnétique on ne voit
jamais de fait même ce qu'on appelle en
chance et c'est une description physique
de quelque chose qui agit sur quelque
chose comme un champ gravitationnel ou
mais c'est un peu comme on se met
directement
voilà exactement comme si je lâche et un
million de pommes et je les vois tout
tomber et je trace des lignes entre où
elle était avant l été après et ça
bouffe
ça me décrit un chagrin que l'ordinaire
sur le point selon les endroits sans
soleil du disiez que lorsque ça va y
avait des sentiments du champ magnétique
c'est quoi le ventre pourquoi est-ce que
l'entente iman du champ magnétique créé
des zones noires a annoncé pas d'entorse
immense et le fait se sait en tortue
moqueuse correspondent en fait à comme
tu l'as dit tout à l'heure un peu un
magazine mans 1-1 stockage du champ
magnétique très intense et et quand ces
structures là vont émerger de
l'intérieur du soleil jusqu'à
l'extérieur du soleil en fait les pieds
de ces structures vont apparaître
beaucoup plus sombre parce qu'on a un
champ magnétique plus intense et qu'on
est moins dense que au tour donc c'est
pas tant que ça c'est une conséquence du
fait que ces structures là ont émergé et
à leurs pieds
on voit où on voit son convoi le pied de
ses structures
parce qu'elles sont associées à un chant
très intense et à moins de placement
donc en fait elles émettent moins de
radiations et c'est pour ça qu'elle
apparaisse plus sombre que à côté sombre
parce que son moins bon selon elle son
sens parce qu'elles sont moins denses et
eux aussi avec un très fort champ
magnétique
on me dit que depuis les photos je sais
pas qui tu es et les photons ça en fait
c'est ce truc la structure là au moins
deux déplacements à l'intérieur a senti
moins chaudes roquettes mais gros à sont
relativement moins chaude par rapport à
alors leur voisinage
2 mais ça reste des verts du coup on
imagine quand il ya des gros
entraînements comme ça il ya du coup
d'énergie qui est ok qu'est stockés dans
ces structures
et quand tu dis par leur connexion c'est
à dire que le coup il va se désengager
d'un coup sévère
ouais alors en fait
ça va pas compenser des entortillé donc
ça va pas changer ça va pas revenir à
l'état dans lequel c'était avant en fait
on atteint un état tellement instable
que lorsque l'on pense que ça aussi ça
va dépendre un peu de en fait ce qu'on a
pas mal de scénarios on attend on sait
qu on sait qu' il ya de la reconnexion
magnétique
pourquoi ou parce que déjà on va voir
des structures magnétique qui vont
apparaître qui n'existait pas avant
on va avoir beaucoup de radiations dont
beaucoup de temps père d'un des indiens
du chauffage c'est à dire que les
températures ont commencé à augmenter
dans des endroits très localisés on va
aussi avoir des particules énergétiques
et donc ça ce sont des conséquences de à
une libération très soudaine d'énergie
est la seule énergie qui qui stockaient
qui peut qui peut être choquer comme ça
c'est l'énergie magnétique et le
mécanisme de libération pense que c'est
cette reconnexion magnétique
maintenant c'est tentant ciment qu'est
ce qu'il va faire et ça c'est ce que
dirait on va dire il ya plusieurs
théories d'autres personnes vont
proposer d'autres choses a avoué en dira
à l'origine de l'éruption à l'origine de
la collection mythique
nous ce qu'on pense et nos
collaborateurs
c'est que ces structures là en devenant
instable donc à ces structures qui sont
en sortir elle devienne complètement
stable et en fait à vouloir grossir
elles sont tellement qu'on finit avec
leur énergie qu en fait avant vouloir
grossir dieu pour étendre un peu vain
pour ce pour relaxer dans une dans une
configuration où elles sont beaucoup
plus grosse et buffet leur énergie leur
densité d'énergie va diminuer
donc sauf qu'en fait ces structures là
elles deviennent tellement grosses qu'en
fait elles vons et s'étendre expands et
devenir ces grandes tempêtes solaires et
en faisant sens a fait avant rome
rencontrer le champ magnétique alentours
que et c'est en poussant dans ce champ
magnétique alors qu'elles ont forcé tout
autour d'elle de art collection
ok ok ok c'est plus facile à rentrer
avec un visuel que remplace donc ça
c'est une explication alors ya certaines
personnes qui pensent que il va y avoir
de la reconnexion magnétique d'abord qui
va engendrer ce déclenchement
d'expansion de la structure mais alors
disons qu alors ce qui peut se passer
c'est que en fait le champ magnétique
est tellement peu statique que ce qui
peut se passer c'est que aux alentours
de cette structure à l'origine qui va
créer cet axe solaire on va avoir plein
de structures qui vont émerger en fait
en émergent elles vont forcer ce champ
magnétique environnants à se reconnecter
et cette connexion va permettre de
soient poussées soient en quelque sorte
ouvrir une route pour l'expansion de la
structure qui pratiquement instable en
fait ça pousse à l'expansion de la
structure donc ce que ça aurait
d'ailleurs que du coup il ya des moments
de la reconnexion du courrier de
nouvelles lignes des choses alors qu'en
fait ces lignes de chant c'est c'est
comme donc s'il est une chance et pas
que l appareil nulle part c'étaient
d'autres lignes de chant qui se sont
connectées entre elles
donc elles ont créé une nouvelle
configuration ce qu'on appelle un
changement de connectivité du champ
magnétique et là encore une fois parce
que ça plaira mais on parle aussi dans
les mathématiques base parce que y'a
déconsidérer des considérations de
topologie
on va regarder la topologie du champ
magnétique ça pour rien hardy polo j en
audio c'est toujours plus compliqué
encore
deux complices terre en revient un peu
au tokamak n'a pas envie de voir ça
c'est marrant parce qu'en fait la
semaine prochaine à une conférence sur
la fusion je vais voir aussi des parce
que je me suis fait aussi des amis dans
la communauté la fusion nucléaire
et ça c'est marrant parce que ça fait
longtemps que je suis pas allé dans une
course de fusion et là ça va être sympa
je sens que je ne vais rien comprendre
mais alors le lien c'est que ce que je
te disais tout à l'heure quand on
commence à parler vraiment de
formulation mathématiques
on commence vraiment essayer de
comprendre la physique fondamentale de
ce qui se passe en fait quand je parle
de physique fondamentale c'est à dire
fondamental à d'autres événements qui
d'autres phénomènes et dans les tokamaks
on a aussi des instabilités alors on pas
en moi ce sur quoi j'ai travaillé c'est
des instabilités de force qu'on appelle
de courant électrique ou en fait quand
on génère ce plasma l'inter des tokamaks
on génère des des endroits on a du
courant électrique a fait et ce courant
électrique en fait si dans un plasma il
peut être très très instable et en fait
il va pas rester tout lisses sont soit
pas rester juste une sorte de nappe de
courant mais cette nappe de courant elle
va changer de morphologie parce que tu
voir de la reconnexion de céline de
champs magnétiques et ça ça va former
dans les nappes de courant ça va former
des sorte d'îlot magnétique
en fait c'est comme si au lieu d'avoir
un champ magnétique tout droit le chemin
mythique comment ça sans tortiller et
former des dix lots donc et il en
libérant de en libérant de l'énergie et
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
le phénomène de la reconnexion
magnétique
c'est quelque chose qui comme ça va
libérer de l'énergie et ça va changer le
champ magnétique
ça va ça va freiner le développement
d'un plasma dans lequel tu peux avoir de
la fusion nucléaire
donc en fait on veut éviter ce genre de
choses 2
donc le travail de matin c'était de
comprendre comment ce qu'on peut enfin
comment se déclenche la reconnexion
magnétique mais c'est encore plus jeune
que ça parce que pendant ma thèse en
fait je n'ai pas travaillé que sur une
couche de courant mais sur deux couches
de courant pourquoi 2 parce qu'en fait
on s'est rendu compte que ces deux
projets courants pourri de rien
complètement instable mais en fait le
développement de ces îlots à l'inter de
ces couches freiner le développement de
10 lots dans l'autre couche donc en fait
que même si ça devient instable parce
que ton à deux ça peut se freiner sauf
dans certains cas au contraire tout
bousiller et tu as une libération énorme
d'énergie 14 octobre en tout cas mais
nous quand tu parles de ligne de cou
ross et c'est toi qui font le tour du
tout comme m
en quelque sorte en fait tu ton plasma
il tombe dans 30 au cac et tu vas avoir
des endroits alors notamment si tu
coupes la section transverses en fait il
va avoir des des couches de courant
électrique qui sont formés à cause du
plasma dans ce tokamak et dans ses
couches de courant en fait il va former
des nouvelles configurations de champ
magnétique qui sont fermés il ressemble
en fait à des ils ont donc alors ces
lots en pâtissons en trois dimensions
donc ils se tournent toutes autour du
tokamak et déjà ça d'avoir des îlots
c'est pas très bon pour le confinement
du classement donc permettre le plasma
avoir du champ de la fusion du clair que
déjà en plus quand il y en a deux soit
tu parviens à limiter la formation de
ses idéaux soit si tu arrives pas bien à
contrôler alors tu te détruit
complètement ton pas cela tu libères
énormément d'énergie et j'en paie ton
placement et une arête n'existait pas
donc le taulier de refaire là
l'expérience de 2 0 n'est que mais si on
arrive à bien contrôler alors ça veut
dire qu'on pourrait avoir des couches de
courant ni forcé d'avoir mais on
pourrait peut-être contrôler ces couches
de courant de manière à limiter la
formation de ces îlots magnétique et
peut-être à augmenter le confinement du
plasma pour pouvoir permettre de la
fusion
ok je passe sur les coupes des coupes en
ce que tu contrôles en on peut contrôler
ses champs de courant ouais alors elle
là ça devient très expérimentale moi
c'est sur quoi j'ai travaillé six sur
des simulations numériques qui me
permettait de voir quand elles seront à
ces instabilités et à ce que ces
instabilités vos conduire à une
libération explosive d'énergie ou pas et
en fait donc à une destruction de ta
configuration et c'est vraiment une
étude de ce plan simulation numérique à
essaie de comprendre dans quel cas en
fait on au contrôle bancaire ne contre
pas maintenant expérimentalement jeu je
saurai pas te dire vraiment au détail
mai dans la quand tu commences avec ton
place moi tu peut injecter des yeux tu
peut injecter du gange était aussi du
courant donc ça c'est tu tu accélères en
fait petit à petit on kasmas et un peu
comme c'est complètement différent mais
par exemple lhc au cern
c'est aussi un taux dans les quêtes
index des particules pas là c'est la
même chose sauf qu'au lieu d'un geste
est juste une particule latin gect du
plasma du courant et c'est chercher tant
[Rires]
de voix c'est comme ça que tu peux
contrôler ou mais alors moi mon époque
c'était une configuration donc cette
configuration avec ces deux couches de
courant qui était plus intéressante est
ce que j'avais mais pour qu'on finisse
en placements face ce dont on s'est
rendu compte c'est que en fait au début
la fusion de la fusion nucléaire dans
les tokamaks on s'est rendu compte que
un placement s'était très turbulent et
que à cette turbulence malheureusement
freiné la possibilité d'avoir un
confinement qui permettait la fusion
mondiale
jusqu'à ce qu'on se rende compte qu'on
va de la turbulence s'auto-organiser et
sachant que c'est magique
attends je sais pas si peut-être que
maintenant ils ont compris moi à
l'époque j'étais encore en thèse que les
grosses questions sur comment s'auto
organisent la turbulence dans un plasma
dans les tokamaks et en s'auto
organisant en fait la turbulence arrive
à créer des sortes de barrières
ce qu'on appelle des barrières de
transport et en fait ça coupe le plasma
qui veut s'échapper vers l'extérieur et
le confinés à l'intérieur du tokamak nul
et ça ça permet de commencer à vraiment
bien confiner le plasma pour permettre
la fusion nucléaire donc attendu dix
mots si j'ai certes formulé dix mois si
ce n'est pas parfait parce que j'aime
bien mais donc du coup avant on se
disait bon placements on peut être
contrôlé et après on s'est rendu compte
que c'était turbulences et dire à cesser
complètement noir ouais mais après on
s'est rendu compte que en fait les
turbulences sont pas non plus n'importe
quoi ils ont une certaine forme et qu'on
peut peut-être la maîtriser c'est pas la
claque alors je sais plus à quel est là
quel est l'historique mais on fait plein
d'expérience de confinement du plasma
dans les tokamaks donc ils sont rendus
compte qu'il y avait sa turbulence qui
freinait le confinement mais dans
certains cas je sais plus si c'est une
injection pas dire c'est une injection
de courant ou je sais pas quoi à qui
permettait à la turbulence de s'auto
organiser directement certains courants
nous a cru jusque là ce matin je me
réveille toi quelle est l'expérience qui
me permettait dans quelque chose
d'incontrôlable est alors en fait c'est
je sais pas si c'est vraiment contrôler
amené la turbulence s'auto-organisent
c'est un peu comme
c'est alors je sais pas si c'est une
bonne analogie à mai a par exemple quand
on voit la hutte de jupiter on a ces
sortes de bombes dans l'atmosphère de
jupiter et généralement quand on parle
de turbulences comme par exemple les
écoulements dans les rivières en fait on
voit des choses
des structures qui vont former de plus
en plus de petites structures et se
dissipait à une certaine très petite
échelle
généralement quand on parle de
turbulences et là la formation de 1 et
comment qui va rencontrer un obstacle et
qui va former des petits flou à côté
puis des putti flou à côté etc
dans le cas de la tâche de mal de jute
dans l'atmosphère de jupiter
généralement une atmosphère va créer
certaines turbulences mais elle va
peut-être s'auto organiser pour créer ce
genre de grandes structures comme l'oeil
de jupiter un dieu c'est dans ce sens là
où la turbulence peut s'auto organiser
et créer des structures grandes
structures doc à s'auto organisent au
lieu de créer le plus en plus de petites
structures en fait avant elle va créer
al'inverse d'une grande structure et ses
grandes structures permettre de dans le
cas des placements de mieux qu'on finit
ce placement est de créer une sorte de
barrière ou le plasma ne peut passer à
travers ces à rien que du coup ça c'est
le grand défi pour fusion du coeur
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais oui je pense qu'il
ya je pense que la question de me parler
de contrôler et je pense que c'est le
principal problème c'est comment ce que
tu commences que tu contrôles ce en fait
avec cette corvée avec cette auto
organisation la turbulence et de pouvoir
confiné le plasma en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que encore une fois tu
atteint des niveaux de stabilité
critique auditives ou où tu peux devenir
complètement instable
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que ces
barrières de transport ou de temps à
autre à levon s'effondrer et puis il
recommence à se former puis s'effondrer
et en fait à chaque fois que ça
s'effondre encore une fois ça libère et
non un an d'énergie et tu perds ton
confirmant donc c'est un peu comme ce
que je te disais tu as hâte à la tête
d'une de sable ou peut-être une sorte de
patate dans les styles je vois le fait
que des plaques tectoniques qui se
rentrent l'une dans l'autre et dans
certains cas c'est tout le tout doux et
puis à un moment donné où ça va créer un
séisme
2 comment est-ce que tu prévois et
comment ce que tu contrôles l'arrivée
d'une instabilité et le déclenchement de
cette instabilité
non je tiens c'est marrant c'est que ces
mêmes questions
même si ça va être sûr d sur des faits
quand on lire sur des phénomènes
physiques différents en fait se
ressemblent parce que dans les éruptions
solaires c'est un peu le jeu c'est de
comprendre comment le ce qu'une une
structure magnétique tout entier dans
l'atmosphère du soleil va devenir
instable comment la prédire une fois que
c'est instable
comment est-ce qu'on va libérer son
énergie donc si j'ai vu pas mal de
publications passé en début d'année 2009
sur l'utilisation du diplôme ning pour
[Musique]
propos notamment le confinement gt1
année parce que c'est bien ça les
cantines dans l'état d'hawaï ouais je
crois que c'est ça qui est assez j'ai
pas vu et sinon est-ce qu'on peut
appliquer oui alors en fait oui à la
paix solarbridge alors oui oui alors
honteux en fait tu me pose la question
parce qu'effectivement cet été j'ai
participé à un programme sur ledit
planning et la physique solaire en fait
t'as que sur le fixe ou là mais sur des
des grands problèmes de l'astrophysique
par la force française donc en mot dire
ça mais des problèmes choisi était le
dit fabrice se prêtait très bien et ça
c'est fascinant parce que je vais
d'abord parlé de plein de types
différente parce que je trouvais que
c'était vraiment intéressant
il ya ya ya déjà des domaines dans
l'astrophysique qui se prêtent très bien
par exemple tout ce qui est la
cosmologie d'un l'astrophysique par
exemple le nuit interstellaire et tout
ça les grandes structures de l'univers
on a tellement de données pourquoi parce
que quand on a la balle ou quand on a
les grands observatoires qui vont
regarder un point crucial
ils vont pas regarder juste une étoile
mais on regarde et plein plein d'objets
astrophysique et donc tu peux faire du
dip landing par exemple de la
reconnaissance d'objets par exemple à
différencier les galaxies avec des
étoiles en tête des classifications des
toiles et puis aussi tu as des as tu as
des tables en une simulation aussi de
deux en cosmologie qui se prête très
bien aux diplômes
je dirais que dans mon domaine c'est ça
a été la réflexion s'est faite il ya
quelques années mais peut-être pas aussi
tôt que dans d'autres domaines
parce que on n'avait pas forcément
autant de données non tout à l'heure
j'ai parlé de la mission de la nasa
solar dynamics observatory qui nous
donne des images en cas de cas dont
camille 96 perd 4,87
et avec ça on m'a dit instruments de ce
qu'on appelle de la télédétection
en fait c'est des images et en plus on
les a à peu près chaque 12 secondes
depuis 2010 donc céder à des attentes
des pétards éclatent d'effets éclaté de
données et en fait on se rend compte
alors il n'y a pas que ça il ya d'autres
choses comme par exemple même la
spectroscopie
on va regarder les spectre de la lumière
où certaines personnes a applaudi
planning point c'est de 2,2 fit et ou de
reconnaître des classes de stacks donc
vraiment dégrafer pouvoir sur les
classifications et elle a récemment
aussi dont j'ai un étudiant en thèse qui
a appliqué alors c'est pas du plan
digues mais c'est d'une machine learning
sur par exemple les profils de champs
magnétiques que l'on observe dans dans
des structures de vent solaire et donc
comme ça si près très très bien et ce
sur quoi on a travaillé cet été c'était
sur les données de la mission sur la
dynamics observatory et d'utiliser dudit
planning pour essayer de répondre à des
problèmes comme par exemple est-ce que
si on a 10 filtres un 10 10 dix
longueurs doute qui ne permet de voir le
soleil dans différentes gares ou est-ce
que si on a plus d'une longueur d'onde
donc admettons que par exemple demain un
détecteur de à ceux des eaux là jeu
complètement à ce que vous pourrez
utiliser toute la mine d'informations
qu'on avait jusqu'à présent pour
retrouver une relation entre différents
détecteurs et un recréer
artificiellement ce détecteur la autre
chose et moi ça m'a vraiment fait moi je
me suis vraiment intéressé à ça parce
que je suis dans un laboratoire qu'il
fait de l'astrophysique spatiales ont ça
veut dire qu'on développe de
l'instrumentation qui va aller dans
l'espace et un coup
problème que l'on a à l'heure actuelle
je suis impliqué dans la mission solar
orbiter qui est une mission de l'agencé
spatiale européenne qui va partir d'un
an dans quatre mois pratiquement jour
pour jour relève en tant que les
papattes on sait pas et le point de sa
mission c'est c'est que enfin la très
bonne chose pour l'émission c'est que
elle transporte à son bord dix
instruments ou de nature complètement
différente etc des instruments vont
collecter beaucoup de données et
notamment des données proches du soleil
go mais quand on va commencer à faire de
l'image
quand la sonde va passer par exemple
loin de la terre ou derrière le soleil
pour nous eh ben elle n'aura pas les
moyens de transmettre ces informations à
nous donc à va devoir stocker à bord ces
informations un moment donné on peut pas
avoir plein d'informations et aucun
problème comme un père brin de
télémétrie parce que non seulement à
bord tu peut pas transporter des
passants sportelli calendar google cloud
et puis aussi bien sur terre on est
obligé de se partager des antennes qui
permettent de recevoir les données des
missions spatiales et ses antennes là en
fait elles sont partagées d'une mission
à une autre par exemple
curiosity sur mars envoi des paquets de
données
il faut que des antennes soient
l'écoutent donc on n'a pas non plus une
infinité de ressources nouvelles et donc
ce que ce que l'on aimerait faire et ça
c'est juste passé notre groupe va
pouvoir le faire ou d'autres personnes
c'est d'essayer donc avec le diplôme ce
qui est intéressant c'est que tu peux
prendre de l'information nécessaire et
évacuer toute l'information qui n'est
pas nécessaire parce qu'on appelle une
âme betting france et table parle de
savoir même pas trié sur un résumé ou
exerçant dans le mur
une représentation électorale une
représentation vectorielle ont vraiment
en fait alléger si possible en fait au
lieu d'avoir pages un livre demande
devant moi et j'ai peint en bleu bas au
lieu de dire j'ai du bleu cyan et du
bleu foncé d'un jg du bleu un double 2
par exemple et donc ça me
j'ai moins de lettres à bala de la même
manière est ce qu'on peut pas réduire
toute l'information dans une sorte de
représentation victoria et et moi ça m'a
vraiment intéressé parce que ça nous
pose des questions sur dans le futur
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir à bord
dudit planning donc des ago des diplômes
ling qui nous permettrait en fait de
soin de trier sûr de faire des
représentations vectorielle de ce qui
nous intéresse nous en tant que
scientifique
en fait d'alléger tous ces problèmes de
tous les mets très intéressant c'est un
des trucs que je me fais pas de pas
grand chose à voir que les spéciales je
reviens dans mon de youtube est ce que
veut il ya pas mal de critiques de
youtube sur le fait que c'est enfin
c'est celle consommée dans le monde
d'énergie comment est en fait un des
trucs qui consomme énormément d'énergie
si l'on voit deux paquets de données
l'internet et il ya un ami du même
problème c'est que maintenant la
compression que l'on a aujourd'hui et va
quand même pas mal optimisé mais bon
elle est encore largement améliorable et
peut-être qu'avec des techniques et
comme ça qu'on m'a dit planning avec ses
cendres maintenant pas mal de trucs de
génération d'image avec tout ça et ça
marche maman a vraiment bien fait
peut-être qu'on peut aussi réduire la
consommation d'énergie moi j'étais
j'étais très sceptique
[Musique]
déjà parce que je comprenais pas
forcément et je voyais je me rendais pas
compte de l'intérêt en fait sur d'autres
problèmes où pour moi il ya encore des
choses à faire à la main en fait
et finalement je me suis rendu compte
que c'est très intéressant et puis pour
moi ç'a vraiment ouvert aussi une
questionnement sur comment ça marche le
dit un ring et tout un pan de recherche
sur la l'utilisation d'algorithmes de
type 2 dit planning est chaud que
s'efface et laisse et les belles bateau
si c'est pas les équations à manier
polito hydrodynamique et l'imbécile
vraiment un 2011 2012
celle qui commence à voir quelques gens
qui parlent de depending bien de
neurones très bien avoir été ultra
qu'heureux j'ai eu les truies qui est
aussi mais c'est nul
j'ai ignoré sa après 2015 message vous
pouvez pas l'ignorer en maths appliquées
gilles aussi m et puis en fait petit à
petit vraiment il ya des trucs assez
spectaculaires ou qui n'ont qu'un voile
et un physique le matin on commence à
voir tellement de données
moi par exemple je crois que c'est cet
été certaines des personnes qui
travaillent dans le diplôme vraiment du
côté des permis travail en fait en
partenariat avec les gens du cerveau
parce que ils ont tellement de
c'est vrai que pour ce genre de pour ce
genre de problème
c'est là on va avoir un nouvel
observatoire qui est en train de naître
d'être finie ah oui donc un des grosses
observatoire en physique solaire je me
rappelle plus le nombre de données
ça va être incroyable dans les pédales
plus au fait j'ai pas du tout suivi les
questions mais sans conclure bientôt
verdon du coup elle soit tu veux parler
un peu de fond d autres projets que ta
recherche
andré sarzi homme aurait avoué alors je
passe je fais pas mal de communication
scientifique et et j'ai commencé la
communication scientifique il ya déjà
quelques années un pareil pour un
concours de circonstances au jeu je
connaissais même pas vraiment le mot en
puissance fusion je n'avais pas vraiment
où l'occasion que j'étais au japon à
l'époque je n'avais pas eu d'occasions
de faire de la communication
scientifique et l'astroballe
ça parle déjà d'une passion le fait de
voir partager ma passion et j'ai
commencé des projets il ya quelques
années en utilisant des technologies
nouvelles notamment des technologies de
la réalité virtuelle et de la réalité
augmentée et donc j'ai développé un
premier projet qui était sur les
tempêtes solaires puisque c'était ça mon
sujet de recherche et j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer par hasard l'un ou par
alain c'était dans un bed and breakfast
on me jette un jeu visiteur un gros pour
un séminaire et je parle à cette
personne qui me dit je travaille dans le
cinéma et puis je raconte ce qu'il fait
car moi je vais j'ai un court métrage
que j'aimerais faire en science fiction
donc on a commencé à parler et puis
sidérant collaborent sur un projet de
code de communication scientifique et à
et on s'est dit ah c'est vraiment
chouette de faire un truc en vr moi
c'est à l'époque il n'y avait pas encore
les oculus c'est en fait il y avait déjà
le des cadeaux et le développeur quitte
donc en fait qui avait pas encore les
malades
c'était encore du développeur c'était
vais pas les versions commerciales et
des cas je pense que je suis pas le seul
mais je n'ai vraiment pas le monde de la
guerre
expliqué en fait la seule réalité
virtuelle ça marche comment c'est
c'est un casque que tu mets sur tes yeux
et était plongé dans un monde virtuel
donc tu vois rien du monde extérieur et
tout ce que tu vois tous les toits en
360 tu peux bouger tu peux regarder
autour de toi c'est un monde qui est
complètement virtuel et donc on sait
déjà où on aimerait faire une vidéo
comme si c'était dans un planétarium
mais accessible à tout le monde
n'importe qui peut voir cette vidéo de
chez elle ou chez lui et au lieu d'aller
de parce que l'état ne sont pas
forcément accessibles à tout le monde
on n'a pas forcément les boys donc le
pas à nous ce soir
[Rires]
donc c'est une bonne idée d'avoir
d'avoir cette vidéo ado qu'au tout début
en fait on a n'est pas encore la
technologie qui nous permettait de faire
des essais avec les manades temps avant
de faire de l'interactif en réalité
virtuelle
donc on est parti sur un projet de vidéo
et je me rappelle parce qu'en fait
j'avais j'avais soumis un propose haye
pour avoir de l'argent que j'ai eus sais
pas comment c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'avait jamais celle de vieira c'était
moi j'ai trouvé ça génial voir parc à
part qu'on était sûr de lui mais
trouvait trop scientifique moi je lui
trouvais trop artistes et on s'est super
bien entendu et j'ai vraiment adoré
cette de travailler main dans la main
avec avec quelqu'un qui est pas du tout
de mon domaine et samassa m'a vraiment
ouvert les yeux et aussi tout le côté de
storytelling
comment est-ce que tu essaies de
captiver le l'imaginaire de la personne
de son auditoire et est donc suite à
quoi comme je suis rentré en france avec
avec mon poste j'ai voulu continuer et
j'ai fait de la réalité augmentée cette
fois ci non avec une application qui te
permet de voir la réalité augmentée non
c'est pas un casque ça peut être fait
sur smartphone ou sur
thales et c'est un peu comme pokémon go
ou en gros avec ta caméra tu vois le
monde comme tu vois avec tes yeux
sauf que en plus de ça tu vas voir des
objets animés qui vont se mettre en face
de toi mais dans ta caméra et tu peut
interagir avec l'état et ça c'était le
premier c'était sur leur stand br le
deuxième ça s'appelle sollbach
expérience pour par l'équipe est là
depuis depuis quelques mois j'ai la
chance d'être soutenu par le cnes parce
que ben on en voit cette cette sonde sur
l'arbitrage est là je développe en ce
moment un nouveau projet de réalité
virtuelle
mais cette fois ci c'est pas juste une
vidéo mais c'est en interactif dont tu
veux jouer un peu avec la sonde avait
cliqué dessus tout à faire tourner dans
tous les sens et donc c'est sûr la
mission sur leur buteur donc je plussoie
sans nous alors on a déjà fini le ce
qu'on appelle le proof of concept donc
le quelque sorte que l'on appelle du sun
store passera par le prototype que j'ai
présentée à certaines personnes de la
mission je représente la semaine
prochaine parce qu'on a une autre
réunion sur l'arbitrage est là en ce
moment mais je développe je travaille
sur le développement plus long donc le
prototype c'est vraiment tu vois les
orbite du satellite
je vois le satellite or en grandeur
nature et tu peux t'amuser a tourné
autour dans le développement plus long
j'aimerais parler beaucoup plus des
intérêts scientifiques de la mission
présentée un peu plus que font tous les
instruments que du coup ça se voit que
tu va l'exposer
ouais alors en fait c'était aussi limité
par le temps que j'ai à l'est le premier
projet là je me rattache j'ai fait à
l'époque j'étais encore au royaume uni
et puis quand j'étais entre enfants je
fais encore des allers-retours beaucoup
ri et je présente et sap en déficit la
de science des supers cran et ses choix
temps c'est vraiment j'adore mais c'est
vrai que à combiner en plus avec
l'enseignement la recherche les
étudiants
donc là on a présenté aux 80 ans du cnrs
tout un week end à gif-sur-yvette au
château dauphin le cnrs a c'est une de
ses antennes là demain je fais la nuit
blanche à 50 ans divine dans un site
historique
la semaine prochaine on est à la fête de
la science donc ça peut laisser sur le
campus deux pas de paris sud est dans un
mois à la cité de l'espace à toulouse
pour un événement corinne se classe 5e
et peut-être l'année prochaine sur paris
je te rrain projet pour essayer de
mettre cette dispense plus disponible
ouais alors déjà là la vidéo elle est
disponible
il ya un site internet ou alors
maintenant comment fait on aimerait
aussi savoir pour pouvoir justifier pour
dire que ça marche on demande aux gens
s'ils veulent vraiment le la vidéo
enfin c'est vraiment quand move et
peuvent directement s'adresser aux sites
web et on la renvoie le fichier surtout
s'ils ont un casque
sinon ça que pour la vidéo ça peut être
vu sur youtube 360
il ya la version française est la
version originale et ça peut même se
soucier avec les google cars board solar
expérience
alors on devrait le mettre sur google
store ou sur apple store est ce
important a été fait pour que je trouve
des développeurs qui sont d'ailleurs
bien viens m'aider
oui mais ça c'est ce que j'aimerais
faire d'ici le lancement et pour solar
buteur ça je sais pas pour l'instant on
est encore en développement pour la
version longue ou mais l'idée c'est de
en tout cas de décembre et à tous les
toutes les équipes partenaires de la
mission est peut-être à la nasa
puisqu'ils vont organiser un événement
pour le lancement de la mission donc et
après est ce que ce sera distribué je
sais pas encore faut que je vois avec
les gens qui m'attriste
qu'est ce que tu as d'autres choses à
rajouter
kyle busch parce que d'autres choses on
ne peut pas parler encore talent
communiste est question peut-être ben je
ferai ce que conclut de conclure
doucement voici 6 6 un message que tu
aimerais qui j'en ai vu que les
auditeurs retiennent deux sets ce
podcast a là un message équation oui il
ya plein de choses
plein de choses dont j'aime parler on
n'a pas parlé par exemple là je suis
vraiment rester au niveau de la physique
solaire et la pièce du milieu
interplanétaire et je pense que de
quelque chose que j'aimerais y connaît
que les personnes qui écoutent penser
que quelque part notre soleil est éteint
on veut dire l'astre c'est là ce que
l'on connaît le mieux qu'on connaît dans
la vie de tous les jours sont tous les
jours on du soleil n'a juste pas je vais
je sais pas si ça fait passer d'habitude
on a tendance à l'oublier ya tellement
de choses que bach cet astre encore à
nous attendre et et là où enfin j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure des exoplanètes du
manque en quelque sorte de contrainte
mais où
moi je trouve que c'est aussi totalement
fascinant parce que la physique solaire
nous permet de mieux appréhender les
autres connaissances que l'on pourrait
avoir en astrophysique
est-ce que des étoiles comme qui
ressemble au soleil mais qu'est ce qui
se dira qu'ils ont une dynamique
différente qui se comporte de manière
différente
est-ce que ça ça nous apprend sur le
soleil comme il était avant
ouais parce que savons nous avons sur le
sol et comme il le sera plus tard par
exemple le problème des ce qu'on appelle
les super éruption parce que les super
d'éruption que l'on observe sur d'autres
étoiles qui
qui envoient des énergies considérables
est-ce que ça ça peut arriver sur sur
votre soleil ou pas le problème des
exoplanètes moi je m'intéresse à
l'interaction fin à tout ce qui se passe
entre le soleil et les planètes mais
aussi à ce qui se passe au niveau des
planètes
par exemple l'arrivée des rayons
cosmiques et une influence avec le vent
solaire est-ce que ça c'est quelque
chose que l'on peut transposer si on
veut connaître l'avis sur d'autres
exoplanètes
est ce que le fait que par exemple une
planète
une exoplanète tourne autour d'une seule
main d'une étoile beaucoup plus actif
que le soleil est ce que ça c'est très
mauvais
parce que cette étoile en verrines comme
particules énergétiques et de ce fait la
vie serait difficile sur ces planètes
ça pose en fait des questions sur plein
de choses et pire on a parlé de la
fusion elle comme un vieux un peu le
parallèle parce qu'il ya là la physique
des plasmas les instabilités donc en
fait nous même si on a l'impression que
et je pense que tu n'entends
l'astrophysique de manière générale en
fait on a l'impression de travailler un
peu sur un petit truc rsa posent des
questions qui peuvent se transposer ou
qui peuvent s'ouvrir à plein d'autres
champs de de l'astrophysique et de la
physique de et sachant que c'est vrai
est vraiment chouette
après d'autres choses dont on n'a pas
parlé qu'on aura pas tant d'autres brut
a assez a évidemment la place à des
femmes en grand
quand chose et on n'a pas réussi de la
communication scientifique et je pense
que je dirais que tout ce que j'apprends
dans de mon parcours et de mes
interactions
ça me fait penser que en fait on on
essaie le plus possible de 2 pouces et
alors que ce soit les filles ou alors
des minorités ethniques qui sont peu
représentées dans le monde de la science
ad on va dire à des jeunes jeune âge
donc par exemple des conférences dans
des collèges des lycées ce genre de
choses mais je pense que et que ce soit
dans la science ou dans d'autres
domaines
en attaque en fait je pense qu'il y en a
un plus gros problème dans l'attaqué
clay dans les sciences et la récemment
eu cette affaire assez horrible à aux
états unis avec app store qui montre le
problème de des liens entre la tech la
finance et puis la science parce que
savait que haïti lab
[Musique]
alors je tanne était un financier
s'élève de wall street ce qui qui on va
tomber
découvert il ya déjà quelques années qui
s'est fait déjà traîné en justice pour
des affaires de pédophilie
et cette personne n'a en fait à jusqu'à
très récemment n'a pas du tout enfin a
été poursuivi en justice mais sans
vraiment être 4e mise en prison et est
finalement été mise en prison et c'est
s'est suicidé il ya quelques semaines
est en fait cette affaire là on a
découvert que dirait pechstein avait
aussi fait des transactions financières
pour financer le m a dit l'abe qui est
un des grands laboratoires de recherche
du amati donc un peu un sorte de pas de
spain start up
je sais pas comment expliquer ça c'est
ça fait partie d'une matinée c'est
vraiment du développement de recherche
d'un fait ce qu'on voit c'est ni rapport
puissant de force et qui inclut
généralement des hommes blancs dans des
hommes et des hommes blancs dans des
affaires très très sérieuses et on le
voit dans qu'est ce qui était un atelier
mattila ben qu'est ce qui donne de
l'argent qu'est-ce qui est politicien
qu'est-ce qui est financier et est ce
pour ça que je dis que ces problèmes de
représentation
en fait ça existe à des niveaux plus
élevés dans les carrières et qui touche
plein plein de plein plein de strates de
l'économie et et qui en fait sont très
fortement jointe enfin fortement
entrelacés les les jeunes avec les
autres c'est un peu con
je veux ça fait vraiment réfléchir à
tout ça c'est pas juste quelque chose de
très candide de dire oui faut plus de
femmes ou de représentation des
minorités ethniques dans la science est
vraiment dans plein de domaines pour une
structure est ce que je veux finir je
parle avec des recommandations peut-être
de vidéos de podcasts de 10 personnes à
suivre pour du nom de l'astronome wire
des recommandations by justement là
comme je parle de alors à un bouquin en
fait j'ai parlé de problèmes de genre un
tout petit peu mais un livre que j'ai re
que j'ai lu très récemment et que je
recommande vraiment à tout le monde et
j'ai pas lu le même moteur à faire
deuxième le premier disque s'appelle
inferior je sais pas comment s'est
traduit en français peut être inférieure
et qui est vraiment très facile aux
questions le le biais de genre dans
plein de domaines de la recherche
que ce soit en biologie en anthropologie
en sociologie en psychologie et ce biais
de gens recommencent qui s'est perpétré
au fur et à mesure des décennies voire
même des siècles et il y en a donc la
motrice qui s'appelle angela zayani a
fait un nouveau qui j'aurai plus de nom
mais qui est par contre sur les
questions raciales et qui je pense doit
être fascinant et monsieur n'est pas lui
c'est du même acabit que le premier
c'est après comme j'ai passé pas mal de
temps déjà et encore si dans ma vie
privée je passe beaucoup de temps dans
le monde anglophone pour les tirer aux
jeux
j'écoute pas mal de deux podcasts il y
en a un que pareil
comment survivre dans mon académie quand
dans le monde astrophysique en tant que
femme que j'aime beaucoup c'est docteur
donc dr dr
la grèce ça on sait d'eux deux filles en
astrophysique
qui qui parle de des problèmes de
l'imposteur qui parle de qu'est ce que
c'est encore comment gérer un peu sa
carrière en astrophysique en tant que
femme je trouve que c'est vachement
intéressant après en fait je en ce
moment j'écoute beaucoup de podcasts sur
tout ce qui est ce genre de problème en
français il ya un podcast à soi et les
coûts sur la table qui sont deux
podcasts qui essaient de déconstruire
tous les problèmes de genre et un kyste
arras qui rend sur les questions
raciales et ça je recommande à tout le
monde est pareil je pense que surtout je
dirais en tant que chercheur on essaye
chercheurs et chercheuses qu'on essaie
vraiment de comprendre le monde autour
de nous je pense qu'on peut vraiment pas
complètement se décorréler son existence
sa présence dans une culture dans une
société et son travail de chercheur je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
faire après des podcasts plus
scientifique va déjà ton podcast
je sais que tu as eu plein d'autres
enfin plein de la plainte personnes qui
font d'astrophysique aussi donc il ya ta
chaîne mais aussi la chaîne de sébastien
il était là et puis et puis j'avoue que
je jure qu'à pas vraiment beaucoup de
chaînes youtube scientifique mais par
contre très peu
j'écoute plus de pots cassés alors il y
en a un que jacques d'or sanglés me
anglais british qui s'appelle lady
infinite multi cage qu'avec un brin cox
et robin
le haddock avec l'autre c'est un
humoriste anglais avec un avec un humour
british que j'adore et rocks et j'adore
enfin je trouve que c'est très fade
c'est et puis en plus très intéressant
aussi
qu'est-ce que j'ai côtoyés bbc inside
games pour tous qui les nouveautés de la
science de manière générale a pris en
français j'aime beaucoup la méthode
scientifique et voilà j'ai un peu fait
le tour des bouquins lancement j'essaie
de lire plus de fictions non parce que
je me rends compte que j'aime bien les
choses factuelles et entre les podcasts
là ce que je lis généralement et ma vie
j'aime bien enfin je me dis que c'est
peut-être bien aussi de lire des choses
le clip jam élections alors ciment parce
que quand vous mangez ce débat avec pas
mal de gens et c'est très prudent il ya
pas mal de gens devant moi en
particulier mais d'autres des amériques
qui qui ont essayé de lire de la fiction
récemment et qui trouve ça moins
intéressant avec eux toute mon affection
ah non mais en plus ça je les hommes un
avis qui a dit qu'ils lisaient de la
fiction pour dormir
ah oui vraiment très bien
non il se trouve qu'il ya surtout si ces
deux très bons auteurs oui je dénigre
pas la fiction ce jusque là toi
l'article toi dit suivi la fiction ou
pas ben justement je suis de ceux qui
agit de ce dakar est quand il y en a en
fait c'est toi six mois la cote
dix questions n'ont pas aussi je lis
très très peu de films quand je lis pas
de fiction par un joli pas de fiction je
pense que ça s'est juste de lire il n'y
a rien du tout il m'aime je regarde la
question surtout du hasard c'est bizarre
mais surtout la science fiction alors sa
hausse
greg egan parce que monsieur fils me
force à regarder écouter
trigano cska moscou mais où black mirror
oc2 truc de science fiction que je suis
mais sinon oui mais je veux aucune vidéo
et à l'écriture dans tout cela en fait
je suis très très petit et je suis de
moins en moins fiction fond c'est à dire
que c'est la série télé que tu regardes
sait rien quoi alors je regarde des
séries comiques jean juste pour les
corps et en dehors des trucs comics jeux
pas de fiction si j'ai vu un peu
d'émotion ouais mais sinon c'est très
très très peu de fiction où je suis je
suis pas très fluctuant mais je pense
que je suis vraiment à ses exploits dans
cette position oui après le fait de dire
que c'est moins intéressant
prenant je pense que effectivement ou
moins récemment c'était beaucoup plus
apporté sur sur des défis par exemple
sur la sociologie et que je trouve super
intéressant mais mais quand tu trouves
un bon livre ii des fictions là et puis
tu peux te permettre d'aider des trams
complètement complètement loufoque a été
des mots aussi des descriptions de
scènes n'importe quoi qui vont au delà
de la réalité fin c'est vraiment ça
c'est qu'ils vont delà de la réalité et
qui se permet d'utiliser des mots qui te
font moi ça me fait vibrer
elle a rajouté encore merci beaucoup à
tous et à bientôt
probable